good morning John I have good news and
bad news the good news is that I have so
much awesome to put into this video that
the bad news is that I have to put
something extremely unknow some in the
beginning of the video to balance out
all that awesome
[Music]
that trap was under my desk where my
feet go my bare feet and now that you
have that non awesome onto the awesome
yes indeed this has possibly been the
longest sequence of Awesome days in a
row since mankind was invented by
Zathura from the planet zorkon who
invented mankind
anyway eight days ago I was in the
studio recording Accio Deathly Cavill is
an actual studio recorded version which
was awesome and which we will talk more
about later the day after that I went to
possibly the most beautiful place in the
world to pick raspberries so that
Katherine and I could make raspberry jam
oh my god that is so awesome it's like
taking candy from a bush then I flew to
New York City where I met the
editor-in-chief of Scientific American
who said that he really admires ego geek
oh my god so if being on NPR is like
being knighted a nerd having the
editor-in-chief of Scientific American
said that he really admires something
that you've done is it's kind of like
being king of nerd dumb for a day for
that day I was king of nerdom just for
one day it was great I suggest you try
it out sometime and then the day after
that me and like 50 nerdfighters
flashmob to Barnes and Noble store and
after you don't know what that means
basically was had a little announcement
that said come to the Barnes & Noble and
everyone did and we were all there and
it was like ha ha ha
and then we went across the shoot-down
oh my god yes that is so cool oh my god
well where's your nerd foursome thank
you
and I called John and threw my phone to
people and they talked to him oh you're
welcome I wish your hair you remember
that weird girl West
or the message on her cell phone that's
me and that same night I had dinner with
Maureen Johnson which was really fun and
then the day after that I met my brother
in Chicago and we got to hang out and I
always loved hanging out with my brother
good morning John
good morning hey and then the day after
that I get to continue hanging out with
my brother except that instead of just
hanging out with my brother it was like
hanging out with my brother doing all of
the awesomest things in the world and
actually even know how many people know
this but this is how that they started
out John and iron
Google Chicago headquarters right now
and we're stuck in the lobby because we
don't know who to call it's like shadow
glass but you have to get down really
low on your knees of anything see it's
going on map they're having a book drive
right now yes indeed John and I gave a
little bit of a lecture at Google's
Chicago headquarters we talked about
YouTube and online video and online
communities in general and it was really
very entertaining and very interesting
and it was good to talk to the people at
Google about that kind of stuff because
you know they owned all of everything
outside of this box they owned it but
that was only the beginning of the
longest day of my life
we then went to a Chicago library event
where there were over 380 nerdfighters
and they were among the most prominent
nerdfighters in existence they included
the short sisters Lina of the butterbeer
experience Britney of the Percel mouths
Lauren Leeanne Kaley and Christina have
the five awesome girls secret sister
Rosie Anna secret brother Adam all these
people all on the same room at the same
time the first time I've ever seen any
of them outside of the YouTube screen
this is the weirdest room in the world
it was almost as if the world was
melting due to the extreme power of the
awesome then I went to was a rock
concert in the park played some songs
with Lena played some songs with LeAnn
played some songs with Lauren played
some songs by myself and if you could
believe it the day wasn't over yet
because then we all with to Chicago's
been--and participated one of the
largest collaborative movie projects
ever and even after that there was more
awesome the gum I played a real live
electrified concert with fans like
pushed up against the stage screaming
the words to my songs to me that was
awesome too and then me and many many
nerdfighters danced all night long to
other wizard-rock bands and yes the DJ
played don't stop believin and that
leads me to the one on awesome thing
that happened in Chicago Liana the five
awesome girls and I decided it would be
cool that people order the CDs that had
already sold out at terminus and so
LeAnn took people's money and took down
their addresses on pieces of paper which
then fell out of my pocket while I was
dancing like a madman so if you bought
one of those CDs from LeAnn please email
me immediately it sparks fly up at Gmail
komm sorry I'm such a spaz and the day
after that I flew back to Montana
witness the joining together of two of
my great friends in holy matrimony and
then I want to sleep and then I woke up
and it was the last day of the western
Montana Fair and I got to go to the fair
and look at goats and llamas and eat
corn dogs and then guru a demolition
derby
so that was my eight days of awesome
John the only way you can continue it as
if you discuss the political situation
in Georgia while giving yourself as a
frank peanut butter mask
yes this video is longer than four
minutes and I will accept whatever
punishment you feel fit to give me if
you want to see John on a peanut butter
mask you'd better subscribe